man on the phone line right now calls
football games for Fox and is an
integral member of the NFL Media Group
talent evaluation community certainly
right there and the portion of the
calendar starting with the combine and
him with the draft and he is most
importantly I believe the voice of the
run rich run simulcast Rav against every
single year he's Charles Davis how are
you Charles I'm doing well and I am
fired up for a run rich run and excited
to still be a part of that that part is
really cool well I'll tell you what I'm
not looking forward to me being sama cam
with Lamar with the Lamar Jackson nah I
think that's I think I if I could take a
look at some of the people that I know
are being pegged by our colleagues to
have mie-sama cam because he's got to be
one of them he's got to be one of them
there's no doubt and what's different
with him rich is that we talked about
quarterbacks being fast in the past but
a lot of that is college fast and an
element of quickness and then they're
very smooth and what they do we probably
thought Vince Young was bass coming out
of college I think Vince was like a big
four six guy right Andrew Luck looks
fast and strong it at Stanford ran into
four sevens I think Josh Johnson
wouldn't run four or five five when he
came out out of University of San Diego
and we thought that was super fast and
Lamar Jackson's gonna break four or five
now we're talking wide receivers speed
we're talking running back speed this is
a different speed at the quarterback
position and that's going to be a lot of
fun for us to watch and evaluate and I
can't wait to see what offensive
coordinator gets a chance to work with
him so let's dig into that because I
think we're all talking about its
viability at quarterback because Bill
Polian thought he should be a wide
receiver quite frankly I mean that
that's that's where we are what about
his pro readiness can you tell me about
about Lamar Jackson sir
it's gonna be an interesting kind of
comparison but for me I compare him to
how dak Prescott progressive Mississippi
State different styles obviously
different body types definitely what dak
Prescott broke big plays running the
football physicality as a junior I think
I said I don't think I know I said I
wonder if it at the next level he might
be an h-back or a tight end and then his
senior year I saw
saude erratic improvement I saw him
better in the pocket progressions more
accuracy throwing the football all those
things I feel the same way about Lamar
Jackson
I thought Rich's Heisman year he was
like a big-time option quarterback that
threw the ball deep off a play-action
off of run fakes and got big plays out
of it and I'm not saying it like it was
an easy thing to do he had an incredible
year but he's so dynamic he scared the
heck out of people when he took snaps
but I thought last year I saw more of
that pocket stuff I saw more of him
being accurate with the football
so like that press guy I think he's
earned every right to be a quarterback
in the NFL and the NFL game has proven
to us over the last few seasons that
they are willing to move and beat these
kids halfway coming out of college and
get them ready to play earlier rather
than the old well that's how we do it in
the NFL young fella you got to learn how
to do it this way and we don't care
about your college stuff it's not like
that anymore and I think that's a
positive for the NFL and for the young
guys coming out all right let's start
digging into the top of this draft here
Charles Davis me John Dorsey the new
general manager in Cleveland became the
latest to step up I mean this happens
every year I mean you could set your
your your your calendars your watch to
it however you want to synchronize he's
the latest general manager of the number
one overall pick saying I'm open for
business if somebody wants to trade for
it so yeah and Jay Dave gentlemen said
the same thing with the number two
overall pick and I'm imagine Chris
Ballard is hoping that both of those
picks stay in their current spots with
the current teams and for some reason
neither of them go ahead and choose a
quarterback because either Cleveland has
gone ahead and gotten somebody in free
agency like Kirk Cousins and the Giants
go ahead and take somebody like say Quan
Barkley second overall and the Colts
might actually be in a catbird seat
position third overall with every
quarterback still up for grabs and their
phone ringing off the hook so what do
you think the Cleveland Browns should do
at the top of this draft going into this
combine Charles Davis we're gonna take
let's take free agency off the table
then rich no free yeah I'm gonna do that
I'm gonna do that because I don't think
Kirk Cousins is going to Cleveland I
don't think he's gonna be part of a
complete rebuild from scratch when he's
got an opportunity maybe somewhere in
Denver or Minnesota to go to
and both of those are top three defenses
in the NFL correct you know so so so
your plan with some pretty good pretty
good
studs there all right so if we're going
to talk about Cleveland that way I said
if I mock draft rich and you know it's
the first of many but I tongue-in-cheek
said that Cleveland ought to keep one
and four and pick quarterbacks at both
spots haha now we know no one's going to
do that but that tells you where they've
been over the years head your bet like
the last time we even came close to that
obviously people look at Washington with
rg3 and then coming back in the forest
to get Kirk Cousins but years ago though
Houston Oilers got Dan Pastorini with
the first pick they had and their very
next picked in the draft it took Lynn
Dickey out of Kansas State
now Dickey found his way in the NFL with
Green Bay etcetera all I'm saying is
they have missed so many times the fan
base is restless the ownership has to be
restless everyone's tired of hearing
about you didn't take when she didn't
take god we didn't take this you didn't
take that we go right down the line of
all the ones they didn't take and they
helped their team look at some of the
draft picks there's good players but
they're not quarterbacks so to be rich
they have to evaluate who they like best
decide on that guy and pick him at one
and not deal with anything else I don't
think you trade out of that unless
you're getting a quarterback out of the
deal that you really absolutely like I
don't think your fan base to stand for
it you've got to go get a guy that you
think you're going to build around in in
there reset 18-point oh I mean that's
really where we are at Cleveland well
what I would do if I'm Cleveland is call
up Dave gentlemen and say look you know
the previous administration acted all
Sam hinkie like and left me with them
what left me with a process amount of
draft picks
what's your package to move down to four
what do you want yeah and then hear what
he says and then try um dial it down
from 11 to about nine and trade up and
get get both your quarterback and say
Quan Barkley one to rip the knob off and
do that and then give the Giants what
they hopefully look for which is a
quarterback that they think is it four
or Quentin Nelson who might be there to
protect you lie in its final days yes
and you know something when I hear you
talk that way you know what I think
about I think about the Atlanta Falcons
when they started there
birth to where they are today and it
started in rich we were together for
that draft it was right after Michael
Vick is after all that happened the city
of unrest there their favorite son will
not be playing and your talk about
drafting someone to replace Michael Vick
and remember the outcry was most Sybaris
remembered out rich because everyone
said go get the defensive tackle because
you're too far away as a team don't buy
the quarterback that he'll get killed
but you remember what they did they took
the quarterback one I mean at three
which was a bat riot and then Thomas
dimitrov traded back into the first
round and got Sam Baker at left tackle
and in free agency got Michael to burner
Turner and that team helps that started
the transformation and they went 11 if I
went to the playoffs of Brian's rookie
year now that doesn't work every single
time but what you're saying that package
is exactly what Cleveland has to go get
your quarterback get a runner like
Barkley to help him out and start
creating that way and of course they
still got talked to Jo Thomason comes
back that's a big piece well I think
that would help I think that would help
him help in that process Charles Davis
here in the Rich Eisen show first coach
up yesterday your guy Jon Gruden who go
you go back in the way back in the day
with and I I'm just hearing him with a
talk about analytics and a lot of people
were critical that you know he wants to
go back to 1998 he's gonna get a
fullback for Marshawn Lynch et cetera et
cetera and and they made fun of that I
think he's he's just playing a little
bit of a game right here okay he is as
on the cutting edge of what works
offensively on a gridiron than anybody
else and I think that the offense is
ready to roll with the current members
they might draft one or two it just
depends on how they tighten the bolts on
defense for the Raiders to win that
division next year and compete what what
do you think it's going to work with Jon
Gruden I think it's gonna work well and
John wasn't coming back unless he went
to a place that had like every coach
talks about who's got a quarterback and
they had one that he liked and that's
Derek Carr and we all know that last
year's record was Oakland was not what
anyone expected we expected that to be a
strong possibility of being a playoff
team and I think we all expect them to
actually be a playoff
so he thinks that you know the things
that he talked about he may have
dismissed analytics you know he's being
smart like a fox you know he'll do that
stuff behind the scenes but getting a
fullback for Marshawn Lynch that's not
out of the question
John wants to grind people he wants to
smack them around a little bit and that
will help in a big way as we well know
the second piece of that is he's already
saying Marcia on a message remember last
year they were talking about ramping
things up and you know kind of taking
care of him and nursing him through the
season that turned him loose in the
playoffs John's like I got to get to the
playoffs before I turn anyone loose
we're not doing that this year so
Marshawn be ready to go because remember
Cadillac Williams sure and when John had
it while he ran him into the ground for
the first three games first three weeks
ready set a record for rookie back
exactly so if I'm Marshawn I top on that
tape and then I go out and run extra
prints everyday and get in the weight
room because John's gonna hanges well
he's gonna be the John McKay when they
say John you can't did it to him 30
times the last three games balls not
that heavy and ask him the poll question
Brockman asked Charles Davis the poll
question I know he'll probably have an
interesting take on it yeah Charles did
you see James Harden last night I
certainly did nice hard to miss and I
and my heart went out to Wesley job his
family and his family what is the most
what is the most disrespectful move in
sports is it what Hardin did dunking on
someone hurdling over someone the bat
flip stare down or the Usain Bolt turn
around and point while crossing the
finish line what do you think Charles
well I'm throwing out Usain Bolt cuz
only he can do that didn't Tyriq he'll
do that to a couple people like wave at
them as he's get in the end zone he did
but I don't count the football in the
track it just looks different cuz and
all but anyway I throw that one out what
Hardin did last night is the one I've
got a son who's playing college
basketball in the Division two level and
I you know I heard from them already
this morning
that's the one that gets their attention
getting dunked Don's one thing because
the guy might be six for your 511 okay
that's going to happen to you
but when you get your ankles broken and
you end up on your butt like that that's
the move everyone celebrates that's the
disrespect
for one I'm going with that one because
that's the one that would keep you up
every night because all you're seeing is
highlights flashing in front of you as
they do it all the time
and it's just a killer that was a killer
he-man Charles I'll see you soon I'll
see if they see it the shop I'll see you
at the shop thank you you guys care to
go that's Charles Davis he'll be in that
meeting later on today the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience